Like Oliver's podcast,
our show loves to shine the spotlight,
on amazing dads,
which is why we created,
the good dad program.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
Awesome,
I love them.
I think it's so great.
(cheering continues)
It's,
it's,
(clapping fades)
I'm excited for this.
For sure.
Today's incredible dad,
comes from Jacksonville, Florida.
And he founded the organization,
Squat For Change,
after a phot went viral,
of him online.
Please welcome,
Dante Palmer.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
How you guys doing today.
(Dante laughs)
(clapping fades)
Dante,
I'm so excited to meet you.
Oliver and I are thrilled to be on this show with you.
Because when I heard this story,
I just freaked out.
Will you please take us back to that day,
that the photo was taken that went viral.
Yeah so it was October of 2018.
My family and I went out to dinner that night,
and we got to the restaurant,
little Liam who is now four,
started to cry.
So we went to the rest room,
and there was no changing table.
I just literally,
got on my perfect man squat,
and began to change Liam.
Isiah, who was 12 at the time,
took a picture of me changing his younger brother,
and we took it back to the dinner table.
I showed my,
well my son
showed my wife the picture,
and she said one thing that kind of resonated with me,
and stuck with me.
It's crazy how,
moms can go to rest room and you know,
change their babies on a comfortable changing table
and dads have to come up with creative or innovative ways,
of changing their babies.
And then two weeks later,
I posted that picture just to get a reaction,
and that night I got exactly what I got.
Six comments and maybe two or three likes.
It wasn't until that morning when we realized,
that it hit the world by storm.
And that's when Squat for Change took off,
two weeks after,
beginning of November.
That's when we really started getting the change,
that we have now.
Oliver did you ever,
Talk to me.
Have to change
Oh, oh God okay.
In a men's bathroom?
So I,
I have had to change my kids,
standing up,
in the back of the car,
this is an amazing,
(Dante laughs)
an amazing amazing thing that you're doing.
You are solving a real problem.
First of all,
every woman out there,
is like hearing this going like,
"Yes!This is so awesome!"
And every dad out there is going,
"Thank you for seeing us,
and recognizing you know,
what we do do."
And this is so important.
And Dante,
Do do?
(crowd laughs)
You said do do.
Well,
speaking of do do,
(men laughing)
Dante,
what is Squat for Change doing?
Tell us all about it.
What did you do?
So Squat for Change is a non profit organization,
that we resort in the appropriate diaper changing sessions,
in all public restrooms across the world.
We are,
now it's two point five,
years later,
two and a half years later,
and we are pushing change,
talking to legislators.
We got you know,
policy changed in New York City,
Baltimore City and Tampa City.
But we've realized that the,
that a conversation,
that's so much deeper than changing tables,
is about changing the narrative
of what it looks like to be a father.
Yeah.
And that's why,
we have endorsed,
the squat for change
have started to build programming in our own communities,
and potentially across the country,
about just getting dads involved.
Get them,
put them in a group,
and just having those deep conversations.
And I wanna be that catalyst,
to say you know what,
let's go ahead and have the conversations,
so we could bring fathers back to children,
and that's why my 14-year old,
my nine-year old,
my four-year old,
we're so close.
Because I talk to 'em.
I give them time.
I listen to 'em.
And I just wanna show the world,
to show other dads,
you know,
it doesn't take finances to be a great dad.
And that's what squat for change is about.
There's change in the conversation,
adding dialogue,
so dads could get more active,
and proactive in their children's lives.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd laughing)
I love it.
(clapping continues)
Thank you I appreciate it.
I mean the fact that you are
Good stuff man.
changing the game,
for dads,
and Dante we love what you're doing so much,
and we wanted to help,
and we've actually teamed up with our friends at Koala Kare.
If you've had a child,
you know what this company is.
(man chuckling)
And they wanna donate,
baby changing stations to your organization.
(crowd cheering)
Yes!
(cheering continues)
(crowd clapping)
Oliver you also have a surprise for Dante too.
Yeah I wanna do,
Dante whatever I can do
to help,
whether be messaging for you,
posting something for you,
you know,
Yes sir.
Partnering up with something you know.
I wanna,
well let's,
I love that you are doing,
you're taking this idea,
and extending it into other areas of being a father too.
You're not just staying in one lane,
and I think that's really important.
So you know,
I'm gonna,
I wanna do some sort of a messaging for you,
but even beyond that,
let's talk,
and try to figure out how we can,
how we can make the,
how we can blow this thing up,
even a little bit more.
I love what you're doing man.
Absolutely.
All right,
well thank you Dante,
and to learn more,
visit squatforchange.com
and thank you Oliver Hudson.
Find Daddy Issues with Joe Buck and Oliver Hudson,
wherever you listen to podcast.
(bright upbeat music)
(bright upbeat music fades)